apple just did something that broke the
tech side of the internet something that
many of us never thought we'd see in our
lifetime they announced their
self-service repair program finally
allowing regular people to order genuine
apple parts to fix their own devices
this is an absolutely amazing shift in
the way that apple does things making it
seem like they're finally turning over a
new leaf especially after the release of
the new macbook pro which is far more
repairable than previous macbooks
earning a 4 out of 10 ifixit
repairability score compared to the
previous 1 out of 10 score on the intel
16 inch model so this is obviously good
news for all consumers but don't think
that apple is doing this out of the
kindness of their own hearts because
there is actually a hidden reason for
why apple is making this change now as
well as many different ways that they
will directly benefit from this new
repair program but before i jump into
all of that i want to quickly explain
how all of this is going to work and how
it's going to benefit you the customer
starting sometime in early 2022 you'll
be able to visit a new apple
self-service repair online store choose
the repair you want to make then check
out the manual to see if you're capable
and willing enough to repair it yourself
then order the genuine parts and tools
to make the repair and then finally ship
back the old parts to apple for a
recycling credit now it'll first be
rolling out with the iphone 12 and 13 so
for example if you cracked your front
glass you can order a new display panel
and swap it out yourself without having
to pay a massive 329 dollars for apple
to do this for you which currently leads
many common people to a local repair
shop that is going to try to sell you on
a crappy unreliable third-party display
to lower the total cost since of course
they're going to be charging you extra
for the labor cost to repair it but
don't get me wrong this new program is
also very good news for independent
repair shops that will now have access
to apple service manuals and genuine
parts especially now that apple has
finally changed their mind on the iphone
13 display replacements disabling
features like face id even if you're
using genuine parts from another iphone
so this is essentially a win-win for
everyone but i do want to mention that
the new program is really only meant for
those who do not have apple care plus
because anyone with that coverage only
has to pay 29
for apple to replace the screen which i
can guarantee you is multiple times
cheaper than apple is going to be
charging you for a genuine display panel
that you have to replace yourself and on
top of that you'll probably be waiving
your right to any sort of warranty as
soon as you decide to fix something
yourself so if you mess something else
up like ripping a ribbon cable while
replacing a component then you're on
your own and some people on twitter are
wondering if apple is going to be
requiring you to purchase expensive
tools like a 250 dollar heated display
removal fixture in order to purchase a
replacement display but i honestly don't
think that apple is going to be going
that far since it's going to be much
more worth it for you to pay a shop to
do it for you but perhaps the best part
about all of this is that apple is going
to be rolling out this service to their
mac lineup starting with the new m1 max
so it makes sense why apple brought back
those battery pull tabs on the new m1
pro max macbook pros so with that said
it's very exciting that this is going to
be a win-win situation for both
consumers and independent repair shops
but now i want to get into why it's
actually apple who is the real winner in
this situation but first let's get into
that hidden reason for why apple is
turning over a new leaf as we all know
the right to repair movement has been
gaining some ground in recent years by
gathering followers and spreading the
word about apple's locked down
repairability ecosystem now this has
already been creating problems for apple
because i personally know people who
refuse to buy apple products solely
because of apple's stance on repairs and
this is especially true for their
macbooks which feature soldered on
storage and other components but the
even bigger problem for apple came in
july 21st of this year when the federal
trade commission formally pledged to
fight unlawful right to repair
restrictions and this came after
president biden signed an executive
order on july 9 asking the ftc to crack
down on companies like apple who have
unfair anti-competitive restrictions on
third-party or self-repair so basically
the point is that if apple didn't open
this new self-service program out of
their own will they would have been
forced into doing it down the road
anyway but now we have the question of
why they caved so early instead of
dragging the process as long as possible
and this is where we get into the
various benefits for apple which far
outweigh the cons so let's jump right
into the first reason or benefit i fully
believe that apple is finally trying to
repair their brand image in an effort to
bring back all of those potential
customers who have been avoiding apple
for years because of these moral issues
like repairability and i believe it's
also very closely tied to their apple
silicon transition for their mac lineup
because for the first time ever apple is
now able to perfectly streamline the
experience and ecosystem of all of their
devices at once thanks to those new
arm-based m1 chips which are essentially
souped up iphone and ipad chips and if
you've been following our mac content
you'll know that i fully believe that
apple's master plan for the new macbook
pros was to create the best laptop in
the world so that they can finally take
back a bunch of the laptop market share
from the windows competition and that
will obviously require steps like apple
repairing their brand image as well as
listening to their customers and
bringing back features like the wide
variety of ports reliable function keys
awesome display quality with 120hz
promotion and a thicker design that
supports better cooling performance so
if apple wants to regain serious laptop
market share they need to repair their
brand image which this new self-service
program achieves now on top of that
another reason is that apple is probably
sick and tired of being sued all the
time for their repairability issues
because not only do they have to spend
money on lawyers and waste a bunch of
time with all of those court hearings
but it also makes apple look like a
villain because they're constantly in a
negative spotlight so it makes sense for
apple to cave in early and give us this
repair program now getting into the next
benefit for apple we already know that
facebook or meta has announced their vr
headset metaverse or in other words a
real life matrix that'll help you escape
the real world and instantly upgrade
your rundown studio apartment into a
million dollar penthouse and as you
might already know apple is preparing to
launch their own vr headset as soon as
next year potentially alongside their
own version of a metaverse so if they
want to gain the trust of millions of
customers they need to start doing it
now which they obviously are so with all
that out of the way let's pivot over to
a completely different side of things
with some real world benefits for apple
to reap right now we were recently
warned by the ceo of nvidia that the
chip shortage is going to last through
2022 and other economists think it could
potentially last years with even apple
warning us that their sales are taking a
hit directly because of all the chip and
transportation shortages so in my
opinion i think apple's new self-service
repair program is gonna help apple
recycle and refurbish as many components
as possible to get through these
shortages and that right there is the
real reason why they're offering credits
to customers who returned their used or
broken parts back to apple for recycling
so for example the number one thing that
gets repaired on an iphone is a cracked
display we're talking millions of
iphones per year and before this
self-service repair program people would
replace their display with a cheap
third-party panel from china and most
likely toss the genuine cracked panel in
the garbage can but now with the new
returned part credit system people will
finally have a reason to send that crack
display back to apple and then apple
will be able to simply replace the
cracked glass and re-laminate it to the
very expensive display panel that was in
perfect condition all along and then
sell that refurbished part to either
self-repair customers or refurbishers
and the store is the same for customers
who return their old iphone and mac
battery packs back for a credit since
apple can very easily recycle the
batteries to make extra profit instead
of people simply tossing their old
batteries in the trash or wherever else
and going even further apple could
potentially go as far as taking return
components apart into various items like
perfectly good condition ribbon cables
which they could then resell back to
customers or refurbishers and in the
worst case scenario when customers don't
return back old parts for a credit apple
will keep the extra profit since they're
likely going to overcharge for the parts
ahead of time kind of like auto stores
who overcharge for car batteries
expecting you to return the old one for
a credit but going even further into the
next reason why apple is going to be
benefiting from this new self-service
repair program the us is currently going
through a widespread worker shortage
ever since the pandemic broke out so
there's a really good chance that it's
getting increasingly more difficult and
expensive for apple to hire and trade
employees who can keep up with all of
the repairs that need to get done these
days especially if apple is expecting to
regain a bunch of laptop market share
within the next couple of years so with
this new self-repair program apple is
essentially offloading all of this
repair work to the customers themselves
saving apple millions of dollars in
terms of having to hire and train repair
technicians and allowing them to
repurpose employees in areas where there
are shortages so from apple's
perspective they're making extra profit
off of selling these genuine parts and
they get to go completely hands off
after that since the customer puts in
their own labor hours to fix their own
iphone but the beautiful thing about all
of this is that it's essentially a
win-win for everyone especially the
folks over at apple who have a variety
of very good reasons to make this
self-service repair program happen with
them now finally being able to get the
right to repair movement off of their
back as well as giving them an
opportunity to show their apple brand
image in an entirely new positive light
so hopefully you learned something new
in this video and if you disagree with
anything that i've said go ahead and
leave a comment below but if you enjoyed
it go ahead and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]